RONALD J. PESTRITTO: Great
to see everybody out here
this morning.
My name is RJ Pestritto.
I am the Graduate
Dean at the college
and a Professor of Politics.
And I am chairing this
panel on the future
of the Democratic Party.
We have three very
distinguished panelists.
Each of them is going to speak
for no more than 15 minutes,
and I'll introduce
each speaker as he's
about to come up to the podium.
And then following the
initial presentations,
we'll have some discussion
among the panelists
and throw things open to
questions from the audience.
We're going to begin
with Douglas Schoen.
Douglas Schoen has been
one of the most well-known
Democratic campaign
consultants for over 40 years.
He was a founding partner and
former Principal Strategist
for the polling and consulting
firm Penn, Schoen and Berland.
And he's also the founder and
principal of Douglas E. Schoen,
LLC, in New York City.
His political clients have
included former President Bill
Clinton as well as former
New York City Mayor Michael
Bloomberg.
As you probably know,
he's a regular contributor
to The Wall Street Journal,
to The Washington Post,
and various other newspaper
and online publications,
as well as Fox News.
Please join me in
welcoming Douglas Schoen.
[APPLAUSE]
DOUGLAS SCHOEN:
Well, first of all,
thank you for the
kind introduction.
I'm very pleased to be here.
And I think in answer
to one of the questions
that I frequently get, yes, I
am still a Democrat, barely.
And I say that, and
one of the problems
I have doing this panel with
two extraordinary minds,
particularly someone
in Bill Galston I
say that, Andrew, particularly
because he frequently writes
in The Journal what I'm
thinking before I've even
had a chance to
crystallize my thoughts.
So Bill, if I plagiarize
you or otherwise take
a bit of your thunder,
I would apologize.
But I grew up in an era where
the two parties were relatively
close, that there were
moderate Republicans
and conservative Democrats.
I count myself now as a moderate
to conservative Democrat,
more in the, I'd say, Scoop
Jackson, Hubert Humphrey mold.
There are very few of us left.
I wrote down in my
notes, a dinosaur.
And while I hope that's
an exaggeration, since I
see none of you laughing,
I realize it's not
too much of an exaggeration.
We live in a world now
that I find as a Democrat,
and I dare say as an American,
deeply distressing and deeply
disorienting because no matter
what your view is of policy
outcomes, we are all Americans.
We have American
interests and we
have, in my judgment,
an overarching need
to pursue them as Americans,
not as conservatives,
not as moderates, not as
liberals, but as Americans.
You hear that occasionally,
less so than you used to,
but the number of people
who really believe that
is precious few.
And as a Democratic centrist who
is hawkish on foreign policy,
I find myself a very,
very lonely man.
I also find myself
lonely in another area.
And again, Bill, I apologize.
Bill's written a column
on what I'm about to say,
and so I don't mean
to be too impertinent.
And I'll put it in the
form of a question.
How many of you have
heard Democrats this year
on the campaign trail of any
ideological stripe talking
about job creation,
growing the economy,
preparing people for
technological jobs or jobs
that may exist?
I haven't heard it.
And it startles me because when
you look at the polling data,
if the economy is
not number one,
it's certainly number 2 or 3.
And if we get any
sort of downturn
into the 2020 election,
it is absolutely the case
that the economy will be front
and center, the top issue.
To my way of thinking,
in the absence
of any discussion of
growth and job creation,
we focus to a degree that
I find almost unimaginable
on redistribution of wealth.
The comprehensive set of
policies from increasing taxes
on the wealthy, wealth
taxes, increasing inheritance
taxes, to me offers a very
clear and compelling narrative
of what the Democratic
Party has come to stand for.
And every new policy
that gets articulated,
if there is a huge price
tag associated with it,
such as the Green
New Deal, you hear,
well, the wealthy
should pay more.
I daresay that that is
neither an economic strategy,
nor is it a strategy
on climate change,
nor is it something
that, in my mind,
is reasonable and
responsible at all.
The other thing that's not
reasonable and responsible
to me is where we stand with
the federal debt and deficit.
And as one of those in the mid
'90s who pushed Bill Clinton
very hard to do a balanced
budget to reduce the debt
and deficit, to compromise with
Newt Gingrich-- and I believe,
if I'm right, Bill, left the
country with a small surplus
when the Clinton
administration was over--
I am appalled that we
have a deficit now that
is in the trillions of dollars.
And there is nobody--
and if there is somebody and
I missed it, I apologize.
But I don't hear anyone of
any real significance talking
about that or the implications
of that for social programs.
Indeed, we tried in the
'90s to have a dialogue
about Social Security,
entitlement programs, Medicare,
Medicaid, Social
Security and a way
to preserve and protect
them for the future.
Paul Ryan tried
in what I thought
was a somewhat ham-handed way.
Obviously, it
didn't work so well.
He's now seeking
other employment.
But that being said, I would
think a responsible political
party would want to
talk about entitlements,
the budget, and our future.
And again, my party
says nothing about that.
Rather, the emphasis is on
redistribution and something
else that I find equally
disarming and disturbing,
which is this sectarian
conflict between the left
and what's left of the
moderate wing of the party.
And the fact that
we are engaging both
on the presidential level and,
indeed, in terms of primaries
with the so-called
Justice Democrats
and the Squad in this
fratricidal process
will only serve to make more
challenging for the Democrats
the difficulty in
ultimately prevailing
at the presidential or
congressional level in 2020.
The question you
would obviously ask,
and of course, given that I'm
here, I would have to answer
is, well, what's going to happen
in the nominating process?
Mr. Schoen, you presumably
have been close to it.
I did work for Mayor
Bloomberg, I guess,
last year and early
this year when
he made a determination that he
would not seek the presidency.
And I certainly
understand then why
he said that he did not see,
with Joe Biden running, room
for two moderates because
the nature of the party
has changed to the point
where they both the energy
and the enthusiasm, as we saw on
the new Wall Street Journal NBC
poll is with the left and the
size of the number of voters
who will vote for a
left-wing candidate appears,
from what I can see
looking at that poll
today and looking at the poll
that Bill put in his column
in the Journal today,
to be somewhere 40%,
50% of the primary electorate.
So OK, given all that,
where do we stand?
That poll, that NBC Wall
Street Journal poll,
has a gap of five points
between Biden and Warren.
That to me spells dire,
dire problems for Joe Biden,
whose challenges on the campaign
trail are well-known, seen,
certainly something either
others will discuss,
we could discuss among
ourselves or with the audience.
But certainly, Biden
doesn't have what
you'd call growth potential.
Warren clearly does.
I don't know how many of you
have followed what she said,
but it is as anti-capitalist as
you would ever want to imagine.
Now, she says
she's a capitalist,
but says when insurance
companies charge high premiums
and have the temerity to try
to minimize their payouts,
that there's something
fundamentally
wrong with that process.
I can understand why she
might want to alter the health
system, but the idea of
using a presidential election
to effectively eviscerate
our traditional notions
of capitalism and free markets
does not sound like, again,
the Democratic
Party that I joined
as a very young man, when I was
moved to involvement by John F.
Kennedy.
And I cite for those of
you old enough to remember,
I think it was a tax cut.
I think it was '63, and
Kennedy saying, rising
tides lift all boats,
or something like that.
Certainly, this is a very,
very different party now.
But I think, given the tightness
of the polling that Bill cited
this morning in New
Hampshire, I think
what we've seen in
Iowa with Warren
within a couple of
points of Biden,
I think Warren, given the
enthusiasm she's generating,
20,000 people in
Washington Square Park,
I guess, two days
ago, I think she's
become the favorite
for the nomination.
And if you've noticed what
Donald Trump has done,
he's been attacking Biden
with his campaign videos
for his gaffes.
He's largely left
Senator Warren alone.
And I think his hope
is to run against her,
to run against the far
left Democratic Party,
and to make Warren, the Squad,
and the left effectively
interchangeable.
Do I think it's likely
to be effective?
Well, let's put it this way.
Trump is in a position where
he is eminently beatable.
His numbers are terrible.
The way he conducts himself,
whether you agree with him
or not, is really not
what the American people
want their president to do.
He flip-flops.
His approval rating
is now in the low 40s.
Some polls have had
it in the high 30s.
He should be somebody
who is easy to beat.
But I don't believe that's
going to be the case.
I think Warren will be a
tough, tough general election
candidate for the
electorate to deal with,
particularly swing
voters in the Midwest.
And if I had to bet, I'd
bet on a close election
with Donald Trump
having an advantage,
despite all the liabilities and
political problems that he now
has.
Look, if we face a recession
of the type we saw in 2008,
all bets are off, and we might
be looking at a Warren-Sanders
administration.
But barring-- that
was also a joke.
I don't think she'd
run with Sanders,
but again, the absence
of any reaction
tells you what you think and I
think of where the Democratic
Party is.
So I'll stop on that
note and leave it
to my colleagues
to perhaps offer
a more informed and thoughtful
presentation than I have.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RONALD J. PESTRITTO:
Thank you very much.
Next speaker will be William
A. Galston, whom many of you
will recognize from
his weekly column
that he writes for The
Wall Street Journal.
He also holds the
Ezra Zilkha Chair
in the Brookings Institution's
Governance Studies program.
That's where he serves
as a Senior Fellow.
And prior to January of 2006,
he was the Saul Stern Professor
and acting Dean at the
School of Public Policy
at the University of Maryland.
And I should add that Dr.
Galston was also the Deputy
Assistant to President Clinton
for domestic policy from 1993
to 1995.
Please join me in welcoming him.
[APPLAUSE]
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Well,
it's a pleasure to be here.
Thank you for coming
out early in the morning
to listen to these
reflections on the future
of the Democratic Party.
Just a few comments on
what we've just heard.
As a partially
defrocked academic,
I have always viewed plagiarism
as the sincerest form
of flattery.
I am duly flattered.
As for budget deficits,
President Clinton
delivered four
years of surpluses
in a row, four consecutive
surpluses, to the extent
that the former Fed
chair, Alan Greenspan,
was wringing his hands
about the possibility
that the debt would be
paid down and eliminated,
making it very
much more difficult
for the global financial
system to make use of US debt
as a safe harbor.
That was $22
trillion dollars ago.
I should also say that I was
at a small event with Senator
Michael Bennet last night, who
is also running for president,
and you would have
heard everything
you wanted to hear
about economic growth
and educational opportunity.
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: He's
[? at ?] 1%, if I remember?
WILLIAM A. GALSTON:
I understand.
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: So does he.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Yep.
He also understands
that Senator Gary Hart
was at 1% at a
comparable point in 1983.
So it's-- but this being
a Hillsdale audience,
I will recur to
first principles.
As you all know,
the US Constitution
makes no explicit provision
for political parties.
You also know that
the founders did not
anticipate the development
of a party system,
and they certainly
did not want one.
But within just a few years
after the inauguration
of the Constitution and the
beginning of our Constitutional
order, we had, in effect,
a two-party system.
And with some bumps in the
road and occasional detours,
we've had a two-party
system ever since.
The two-party system appears
to be our Constitutional fate.
Is this bad news?
I think not because it turns
out that in an increasingly
large and diverse country,
political parties turn out
to be essential
ways of organizing
arguments about the
future of the country.
And that is the
ultimate justification
of our party system.
Or more precisely,
to propose responses
to the major problems facing
our country within the framework
of defensible interpretations
of our Constitutional order.
Now, this role for
the parties involves
in part debatable specifications
of what these problems are.
Sometimes the
parties agree on what
the problems are,
and only disagree
about responses or solutions.
Today, as sometimes
happens, there
is disagreement
between the parties
both about the most
important problems
facing the country and the
nature of the solutions
to be offered.
Nonetheless, I have come neither
to bury the Democratic Party
nor to praise it, but to analyze
the current situation facing
the party and the country.
So let me offer a list of what
I think most people would agree
are problems
confronting the country.
First, the economic
and social consequences
of the profound
economic transformation
that we have been
undergoing for decades
and continue to undergo
with a constant wave
of technological innovation.
Second, the implications
of increasing
demographic diversity, which
is baked in to our population,
even if we slammed
the doors entirely
shut on immigration tomorrow.
What are the implications of
this demographic diversity
for public policy and
also for social cohesion?
The clash, which I think is
quite a systematic clash,
between what I'll
call traditional
and progressive
cultural outlooks.
Shifting gears, the economic
and military implications
of China's rise for
America's role in the world.
Authoritarian challenges
to the post-war hegemony
of liberal democracy.
And finally, and I would
add on a Constitutional
note, the implications of
the hollowing out of Congress
and the shift of power both
to the executive branch
and to the judiciary.
Now, because our large
and diverse country
has only two major parties,
thanks to our first
past the post system,
each party of necessity
is a coalition with internal
differences and also fissures.
Within today's
Democratic Party, there
are disagreements about the
best responses to the challenges
that I've enumerated.
And because of that, it is the
party's caucuses and primaries
that will determine the
agenda that the Democratic
Party presents to the
country as an alternative
to a Republican Party
which is now dominated,
as rarely before, by the
figure and the orientation
of the Republican president.
So simply put, the present
of the Democratic Party
is an argument about the
future of the Democratic Party.
And what's going on
in this primary season
may be disorderly,
but it is not trivial
because it is an argument
about the future of one
of the two great and
enduring political parties
in this country.
Now, what is the argument about
within the Republican Party--
rather the Democratic Party?
Well, in part it's an argument
about economics, how much
and what kind of
government intervention
is needed to rectify the
imbalances that have developed
in different sectors
of the economy,
and I would argue
among different regions
of the country.
And these regional divisions
are real and consequential and
worrying.
So what is the right balance
of market-based mechanisms
and command and
control measures?
To what extent is the
increasing concentration
of ownership among fewer
and fewer businesses,
in many sectors of the
economy, a problem for growth
and innovation, a problem
that the antitrust division
of the Justice Department
in the Trump administration
is now wrestling with?
Can a partnership
with corporate America
be consistent with the
objective of economic growth
that benefits all
classes and regions?
Or should the Democratic
Party treat corporate America
as a foe that must
be brought to heel?
There are many other
divisions within the party
on immigration, on health care.
Is it Obamacare?
Obamacare plus a public option?
Medicare for all?
What should we do
with our troops
in Afghanistan, the
so-called Endless War?
Should they be pulled
out unconditionally?
Should we demand
tougher conditions
than Khalilzad has so far?
Should we leave them
there indefinitely?
What about the
Trans-Pacific Partnership?
I think it's fair to say that
Senator Elizabeth Warren would
like to get to no on the TPP
and former Vice President Biden
would like to get to yes.
What about the size
of the defense budget?
Some Democratic
candidates believe
that the defense budget
is about right sized,
and others think
it's much too big.
How much of an enemy is China?
Are we facing a new
Cold War or does
China present us with a mix of
competition and cooperation?
There is also
political disagreement.
Does President Trump represent
an historical detour,
as Joe Biden would have it, or
an historical discontinuity,
as many other Democrats believe?
And in parallel with
that, is the task
of the Democratic Party to get
the country back to normal,
which is more or less the
Biden position, whatever
you think normal is?
Or is it radical
structural change,
which is the basic
position of the left wing
of the Democratic Party.
What's going to happen?
I don't know.
I genuinely don't know.
If things continue
as they're now going,
we are looking, in effect,
structurally speaking,
at a rerun of the 2016 primary
between Hillary Clinton
and Bernie Sanders, although
the figures representing
those two different forces
in the party are different.
I agree that at this
point the force appears
to be with Senator Warren.
On the other hand, her appeal
is to a relatively small slice
of the overall demography
of the Democratic Party.
And the African-American vote
is key after the early primaries
and caucuses, and there, Joe
Biden has fully 50% support,
and he doesn't seem
to be losing it.
So I think it's a fair fight.
There is no way of predicting
the outcome for sure.
But I can say this.
History is a series of
sequential consequential
contingencies, each one shaping
the range of possibilities
for the next.
It is inevitable that the debate
in today's Democratic Party
will be shaped in part by the
powerful figure of Donald Trump
and what he represents.
And the Democratic
Party is wrestling
with the question
of the best argument
to make against what
President Trump represents,
given the fact that some
of what he represents
overlaps with at least
some of what the Democratic
Party believes.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
RONALD J. PESTRITTO:
Well, thank you.
Our third speaker
this morning will
be Andrew Sullivan, who is a
contributing editor at New York
Magazine, and is also a
blogger and an author.
He was The New Republic's
youngest Editor In Chief,
and he also worked for Time,
for The New York Times Magazine
and served as a Senior
Editor for The Atlantic.
He joined New York Magazine
as a contributing editor
in 2016, where he covers
politics and culture
and occasionally
writes features.
He also has two new books.
One is titled Keeping
the Faith, which
is a spiritual memoir
about the future
and meaning of Christianity
in the 21st century.
And he has a 30-year
retrospective
of essays and reviews
titled Thinking Out Loud.
Please join me in
welcoming Andrew Sullivan.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW SULLIVAN:
Thank you very much.
Just to clear up a small,
small point of fact,
the last two books
that you cited
have not yet been written.
They've been put on hold
until the Trump period is
concluded in some way or other.
For the record, I'm not a
Democrat, never have been,
but neither have I
ever been a Republican.
The only thing I've ever
been really is a Tory.
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: Wet or dry?
ANDREW SULLIVAN: I was
very sort of on the rocks.
Let's put it that way.
So just a few thoughts
about what has been said
and what we're talking about.
I think this is an incredibly
fertile moment for the left,
I think, for a couple
of obvious reasons.
And you see this not just
here, but in Europe as well.
And the first is that clearly
market capitalism is failing
most people in the West.
The ability to actually
raise most people's standard
of living to afford a house,
to afford college, all the core
things that people want to
make themselves a better life--
I have someone whispering
in my ear here.
OK.
Where was I?
WILLIAM A. GALSTON:
Market capitalism.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Market
capitalism is failing, clearly
failing, and this is creating
a huge demand, especially
among the younger generations,
for radical reform.
If you look at the next
two generations' views
on the old issues
of right and left,
they are further left than
in any time since the '30s.
They don't like capitalism
for the first time, really.
A generation of
Americans do not like it.
And you can see--
and same also in the
United Kingdom, which
I know a little bit about.
You can see it's also
the case in the UK.
How to fix this?
How to fix the fact
that everybody's
working harder than ever
and only a tiny proportion
of people are
benefiting massively?
That's the question
that people are asking.
And secondly, I think
the other issue that
is propelling the left
is the climate crisis,
that as the world hurtles
towards unprecedented climate
turbulence and mass migration
as a consequence, obviously,
government has a role to
play in preventing such
a catastrophe from unfolding.
And most people, especially
those, again, under 40,
who will have to live in
that world, want change--
big change-- in order to
prevent that from happening.
So it is, in my view,
a really fertile time.
A program for
redistribution of wealth
has enormous potential
as a vote winner,
whether you agree
with it or not.
Radical efforts to
prevent climate change
are increasingly popular.
And it should be, I
think, a walkover.
Why [? isn't ?] it a walkover?
Why, in fact, the
Democrats and the left
in general are struggling
is very interesting.
In the last general election
in the United Kingdom,
the Labour Party led
by Jeremy Corbyn,
the most far left individual
in the history of British
politics, let alone
as Prime Minister,
once he laid out his
manifesto at the beginning
of the campaign, which
is basically massive
redistribution,
building of houses,
and an overhauling of market
capitalism in the United
Kingdom, he gained 20
points in the campaign.
That is why the Tories are in
such problem because the Labour
Party's message of
redistribution is actually
increasingly popular.
I think there are two
reasons this is not
working for the left, and
the first is immigration,
that people are
prepared, I think,
to move to the left quite
radically on economics.
But unless they're reassured
in this very turbulent time
that their countries
aren't simply open borders
to anybody who
wants to come there,
they're not going
to get a hearing.
The Democrats'
position on immigration
is now so far to the left,
so far towards open borders,
that it disqualifies them in the
minds of many other people who
still believe that there is such
a thing as the nation state,
there are such
things as borders.
And the Democratic
Party seems to be
completely oblivious of this.
The second reason is
intersectionality.
It is the shift within the left,
away from the economic Marxism
to a cultural Marxism, in
which the various groups--
I don't need to explain
this at Hillsdale--
individuals are characterized
by their membership
in certain oppressed groups.
Society is understood
entirely as a matter
of power, not freedom,
and the only thing
to do is to resist
those in power
on behalf of those
out of it, and seeing
that as the core
reality of humanity
divided by race, gender, sexual
orientation, gender identity.
And these themes are
being used and spread
throughout the
educational system,
including the elementary
school system now,
as a way to transform society
in the most radical lines
to abolish nature, to abolish
the difference between men
and women, to insist that
all differences in outcome
in almost any line of
work or area of expertise
is entirely due to forms of
oppression and nothing else.
This ideology of course,
is now the orthodoxy
being taught across
American education.
It is the orthodoxy being
taught every day deliberately
by The New York Times.
It is not something that most
regular, normal Americans
believe in.
They still believe in the ideas
of opportunity, meritocracy.
They just want to be
able to succeed, and know
that in this particular economy
the chances of their succeeding
is extremely small.
In the process of the elites
of the Democratic Party left,
moving drastically to the
left, and indeed moving
towards open borders
more explicitly,
is a function also
of Donald Trump,
that Trump's genius, if
you want to call it that,
is to so polarize the
country to advocate
such extraordinary
measures on the far right,
that the far left has
been emboldened by this.
And the liberals in
the Democratic Party
have to say, yes, we know
we're up against this figure.
Yes, we know he's doing all
these things that we despise.
But let's be sensible
and let's be moderate.
Let's not take the bait.
Let's not go crazy.
Let's not just oppose him
in every single respect
to the extreme.
That's a very, very difficult
case to make in the mood right
now on the left and the right.
So my view, for
what it's worth--
and all this has
made incredibly worse
and has been created in
part by social media, which
means the elites are really
talking to themselves.
They have no understanding
what's happening outside.
That's why they could have
nominated Hillary Clinton--
an insane act given her
popularity and her credibility.
And now they've decided
they want Hillary 2.0,
but not quite as charming.
But they cannot help themselves.
And the liberal tradition,
liberalism itself,
has collapsed.
You see this also across Europe.
Center left parties have
completely imploded.
And the Labour Party in Britain,
the biggest and most successful
one recently, has only survived
because the far left has taken
the whole thing over.
So I think, short
term, we're going
to have major polarization.
And the Democratic Party,
if they nominate Warren,
will lose.
That's what I suspect.
Of course, anything can happen.
But I also think
that if we continue
with what we have
in power and we
have no reforms in
the economy, then that
will be a very short-term
victory for the right.
And what's coming is a
landslide for the very far left.
It'll come.
When it comes is simply
a matter of time.
And whether the Democratic
Party can marshal that energy
to win elections is
the real question.
That they're the most useless
political party in the West,
and they can screw it up.
But the tide is with them.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RONALD J. PESTRITTO: OK.
Thanks to all our panelists
for those presentations.
I want to give them
some opportunity
to respond to one another.
Would anyone like to begin that?
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: I'll begin.
RONALD J. PESTRITTO: Please.
And if you--
I think the microphones
at your seat are working,
and I'll kind of referee
it from up here if I can.
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: Bill,
how would you respond
to Andrew's presentation?
Is there an emerging
Democratic majority
that's just 10 or 15
years away or sooner?
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Is this--
RONALD J. PESTRITTO: It is.
It is on, yes.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON:
I guess Andrew
has a much clearer
crystal ball than I do.
If I wanted to be
contentious, I would
say that the Tories in the
UK are giving the Democrats
a pretty good run for their
money for uselessness,
but let's not go there.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: We can.
The election's coming up.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Oh, yes.
I don't share the view that
the Democratic Party has
capitulated to far left forces.
The nomination of
Hillary Clinton
was labeled an insane act.
Would it have been saner to
nominate Bernie Sanders, who is
the only available alternative?
I don't think so.
And as I read, for example, the
Democratic primary electorate
in New Hampshire--
just in today's
Wall Street Journal
I published a piece about
the views of that electorate.
They are not in
favor of revolution.
There they are in
favor of reform.
They would like
that reform to draw
on the best ideas and energy
from both political parties.
And I think that the view of
the Democratic Party that you
see if you look at it through
the prism of campus leftism
is really a crazy mirror
caricature of the actual rank
and file of the party.
No doubt the Democratic
Party of today
is nothing like the
Democratic Party of 1960,
but I hasten to add that the
Republican Party of today
is nothing like the Republican
Party of 1960 either.
Both have changed.
Neither has changed
in a direction
that I particularly like.
But I think perhaps it's
my role on this panel
to be a defender of
the Democratic Party
because no one
else in this panel
seems to want to
occupy that role.
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: But
Bill, you were defending
a Democratic Party in New
Hampshire that included,
I think, if I have it right,
30% to 40% independents.
Of that group, as I
remember your article,
30% voted for Donald Trump.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON:
That's correct.
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: So the
group you were describing
is not really the Democratic
electorate as I know it
or as Andrew tried to
describe it, right?
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Wrong.
DOUGLAS SCHOEN:
No, it isn't wrong.
That's clearly right.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Let me
suggest a compromise, which
is, in fact, Bill, most
regular Democratic voters
are not far left at all.
It's irrelevant.
The activist base is
selecting far left candidates
to pick from, with the exception
of Biden, who is clearly
too old to do what he's doing.
And it's those elites that
are determining the policy.
And I see absolutely
no one, for example,
among any of the Democratic
candidates that's
pushed back the slightest
bit on the question,
say, of immigration or of
the social justice agenda.
In fact, they've all
completely capitulated to it.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: I don't
agree with that, either.
For example, Biden was
not the only Democrat
who pushed back
against the proposition
that unauthorized
border crossing should
be decriminalized, not
the only one by far.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Well, who else?
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Who else?
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Because I think
they all put up their hands.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Bennet, no.
I believe Senator
Klobuchar from Minnesota
did not accept that proposition,
and a couple of others.
It divided the party.
And many of the people who
put up their hands, I think,
will have cause to regret
it, if they're not already
regretting it.
I would say one other
thing, that if you
have lots and lots
of people fighting
for half of the
party and only one
or two people fighting for
the other half of the party,
there is a certain tactical
advantage to the less densely
populated field.
And Senator Sanders is not
fading nearly fast enough
for the Warren forces.
And as long as he
stays in the race
and gets above
the 15% threshold,
she is going to have a very
hard time commanding a majority
within the Democratic Party.
So I guess I just have I have
a very different view of what's
going on.
And I do not agree
with the proposition
that the elites are driving
the entirety of the debate
within the Democratic Party.
RONALD J. PESTRITTO: Maybe I'll
put one question to the panel
before we open it up.
I haven't heard the issue
of gun control raised
yet this morning,
but it's certainly
very much on the current
public policy agenda.
And I wonder,
especially as important
as that is to some of
the electoral battles
that you're all
speaking to, if you
might say something about the
party in the gun control issue.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON:
Well, I'll be happy to.
First of all, the
Second Amendment
is in the Constitution.
And as interpreted
by the Supreme Court
in the Heller decision,
it's the law of the land.
And so the question
is, what is permissible
within the Constitution as
interpreted by the Supreme
Court?
And of those things
that are permissible,
what is good public policy?
And do Democratic proposals
map onto those contours
comfortably?
I would say this.
Every single survey
that I've seen
shows between 85% and
90% public support
for universal background
checks, every single one.
A majority of Democrats,
Republicans, Independents,
and NRA members are
all in favor of that.
And I believe that the
support for that proposition
is strong enough so
that a candidate who
takes the other side
of that position
is going to have a problem.
Do I think that the
involuntary confiscation
of classes of weapons is either
constitutional or politically
prudent?
No, I don't.
But there is a lot
of daylight between
the involuntary confiscation of
classes of weapons on the one
hand and the status
quo on the other,
and it's the task
of reasonable people
in both political parties
to find that sweet spot.
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: Let
me try to put that
in the context of campaigning.
And I'm going to try to
talk in plain English.
You will win a
Democratic primary
taking as strong a
position on gun control
as you feel prudent.
There is a sense,
and I think rightly,
of the moral urgency
of background
checks of a universal nature,
red flag laws, lie and try.
And yes, there is
65%, 70% support
in the Democratic primary
for an assault weapon ban.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: So you're
predicting the nomination
of Beto O'Rourke.
Is that correct?
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: I think I made
very clear that that is not
what I'm predicting.
And I do think you heard me.
Anyway, but what I would say to
Bill's point is the Republicans
and their leader, Mitch
McConnell, has basically said,
I'm not doing anything
unless the president's
going to sign it.
And as we sit here today,
it doesn't look to me
like anything's
going to get done.
We might-- and Bill
could be right on this--
the overwhelming power of
the background check issue
could be one that gets through
the Senate and the House.
But despite the numbers
that Bill cites,
which are absolutely
correct, Mitch McConnell
has been unfailingly resistant.
And the real change is
in the 2018 midterms.
I was working for Mike
Bloomberg's PAC, I USA.
We used the gun issue.
We used it unabashedly
and without any apology,
but of course, supporting
Second Amendment,
and we had breakthroughs
in 21 of the 25 districts
we campaigned in.
And in none of
those districts was
support for gun control anything
but a political positive.
So I think the Republicans are
behind the curve on the issue,
but I do also think that
the strength of a very
weakened, and I dare say
allegedly corrupt NRA,
is such that the other side of
the issue has been weakened.
What I will say as one of
probably the few people here
who is debated the
issue extensively
against the right is
the argument against gun
control of the type
that Bill is describing,
or I am both advocating
and describing is,
you're taking our guns away.
And as specious as I think that
claim is if you're just talking
about background
checks, until recently,
that claim and the fervor
that the right attaches to it
has been surprisingly effective.
As I said, 2018, much
less effective, and it
is, in my mind, an open question
how the issue will play out
in 2020.
But if the Republicans don't
embrace some sort of compromise
on getting rid of the
loopholes on background checks,
I think it'll be a huge
potential Democratic issue
in the general election.
RONALD J. PESTRITTO: OK.
I think with that, we will go
to questions from the audience.
There are some folks
with microphones.
And so if you could raise your
hands and they will come to you
and let you use those to
address a question to the panel.
I see several hands over there.
I'll let you guys
just figure that out.
Please, sir.
AUDIENCE: My question involves
whether the other two gentlemen
agree or disagree
with Mr. Sullivan
that capitalism has been
an unabashed failure
in the Western nations.
I don't feel that--
I feel that the
younger generation
has had great
difficulties because
of the increase
in college tuition
and some of those aspects.
But to call it an unabashed
failure in the West
astounds me.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Can I
just respond to that?
Obviously, capitalism has
been an incredible success.
If you look at the entire world.
And it's certainly been a
success in the last 20 years
for large numbers of people
in the developing world.
It is not working
for middle class
and working class Westerners.
It is actually making
it incredibly hard
for them to scrape
together a living.
The data is simply unanswerable.
The idea that a capitalist
economy will benefit everyone
has disappeared because
it is not true anymore.
And I think people on the right
need to get real about that.
That's why we have Trump.
That's why we have
a rejection of what
you might call neoliberalism
because in the end,
it was a victim of
its own success.
And the forces of mass
migration and of globalization
and of free trade
have essentially
decimated the potential for
ordinary people in the West
to actually earn a
living and to see
the living standards of their
kids be higher than their own.
And right now, their
living standards
are going to be lower.
And that is not a success.
I'm sorry.
It's not a success in the last--
we're talking about this
particular period in time,
and it's really hurting.
That's why our entire
politics are the way they are.
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: To me, the
answer that Andrew just
gave now as opposed
to his earlier answer
is very close to my own view.
Look, if you look at the
numbers that Donald Trump cites
in each of his speeches,
it's hard to disagree
with his reports about
lowest unemployment
rate, highest levels of
employment for minorities.
And it's hard to
look at those numbers
and say that we have been
anything but successful.
When you look at the
poll data, his rating
on handling the economy
is about 10 points,
12 points higher than his
overall approval rating.
But Andrew's right.
It would be absolutely wrong
to conclude from those numbers
that we've had the level of
upward mobility and reduction
in income inequality that
a healthy society sees.
To me, the reason I talked about
jobs in my initial presentation
is the Democrats
need a narrative that
is both pro-capitalism,
pro-growth.
I think it's what Bill,
if I can flatter him again
with plagiarism, called
inclusive growth.
And I think if the
Democrats are able to do
that as part of an overarching
strategy that doesn't
necessarily focus
exclusively on culture,
they will be inestimably
stronger in November 2020.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON:
My view is that if you
look at the history
of market economies
extending back
hundreds of years,
they go through periodic
episodes of crisis
or deep challenge.
And the task in each case--
and it has been
successful up to now--
is to make the necessary
policy adjustments
in the framework
of market economies
so that they do achieve
their objectives, including
widespread benefits
to the populations,
not just of developing countries
but of developed countries
I believe that in the wake of
the economic crisis of 2008,
2009, we are again in
one of those periods.
The argument within
the Democratic Party
is whether capitalism should
be adjusted or abandoned.
I confidently predict
at the end of the day
that the market economy in the
United States will be adjusted,
not abandoned.
There will be
responses to a series
of particular
challenges, including
the cost of health
care, the cost of higher
education, the fact that
many young people today,
even in their 30s, view the
prospect of home ownership
as almost unimaginably
distant, which
is a profound transformation
from the way things were.
In other words, we're
not in the 1990s anymore,
and the optimism that we had
about having a winning hand
and needing only to
play it out reasonably
skillfully has dissipated,
I think, for good reasons.
And we now have to think more
deeply about the adjustments
to the market economy
that are necessary.
Many Republican
thinkers, for example,
are talking about systems of
tax credits or wage supplements
for low and moderate
income workers.
Not to put too
fine a point on it,
that is a form of redistribution
within the market system.
Many Democrats agree
with that approach.
I would also say, in conclusion,
that the government every year
publishes a comprehensive
report on income and poverty.
And the report that
came out just last week
showed that, corrected for
inflation, the median earnings
of men working full
time, year round have not
increased since 1973.
Those are official government--
ANDREW SULLIVAN: That
is a failure, right?
That is a failure.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: That
is, I would say, evidence,
at the very least, that
something has gone wrong
that needs to be fixed.
Whether socialism is the name
of the fix I am very skeptical.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Me too, Bill.
I'm not advocating.
I'm just trying to
analyze what's going on.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Me too.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: I would
support Joe Biden over that.
But I'm just trying
to explain why
I think the forces that have
swept over people, which
they're responding to by
very understandably wanting
to curtail free trade, wanting
to curtail immigration,
wanting to make themselves feel
more secure in this economy,
is one of the central
issues of our time.
It's defining all
of our politics.
And again, I think if it
weren't for immigration
and if it weren't for
their cultural Marxism,
Dems could do really well
and adjust capitalism, just
in a more redistributive way.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON:
Well, I think
we largely agree on that point.
Whether we agree on
the underlying analysis
is interesting.
So for example, let's take
full time male workers
as an analytical baseline.
Two big things that have
happened in the past half
century.
First of all, the surge of
women into the paid workforce--
that is domestic competition.
And secondly, the
creation of what
amounts to a global
labor market,
which did not exist until
the collapse of communism,
the fall of the Berlin Wall,
and the entrance of China
fully into the global economy.
I think we have not yet begun
to think through how countries
like the United
States can respond
to huge tectonic economic
forces like that.
And I don't think
those responses are
going to look a lot like the
1990s, my favorite decade,
or the 1980s, presumably
the favorite decade of a lot
of the people in this room.
RONALD J. PESTRITTO: OK.
Let's get another question
over here, please.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, gentlemen,
for participating today.
And this kind of follows
the first question
is, if the left is in
an inexorable movement
to socialism, the
phrase of something
about the definition of
lunacy is doing the same thing
and expecting a
different result,
how do socialists on the left
expect a different result
from every instance we've
seen of socialism, i.e.
the Soviet Union and its
demise and Venezuela's sinking
into a pit of--
if I were to quote my
president, a shithole.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Well,
to put it as simply as--
I can make my answer very short.
I do not see the
Democratic Party
as being on an inexorable
path towards socialism.
I see it as being in the
middle of a debate as to how
contemporary capitalism
can be adjusted
so that the general
welfare is better promoted
than under the status quo.
That's the real debate.
That's the
Constitutional debate.
What does the general
welfare require
in current circumstances?
The Democratic Party will
never arrive at Jeremy Corbyn's
solution, never.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: That's
what the Blairites
said before it happened.
I'm just trying to
explain it, understand it.
That's all.
I just think it's a
very fertile time.
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: I think if you
look at the rhetoric of Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren,
who were getting 40% together
in the Wall Street Journal
poll out today, higher
with their combined
vote than Biden's 30%,
their rhetoric is explicitly
socialist, their solutions
clearly socialist.
And I think Bill's right.
I don't think capitalism
is going away anytime soon,
but we're going to have a
robust debate of the type
that I think, even a
few years ago, would
have been unimaginable.
And I think a good part of the
reason is what Andrew suggests.
But let me just offer a
slightly more straightforward
explanation.
When we all got out of
school, the presumption--
at least in my world and what
I saw when I came of age--
was that there were
limitless possibilities.
Tuition was cheap.
Health care was
available and affordable
through private means.
Or even if you paid yourself,
it didn't cost you much.
Jobs were plentifully available,
opportunities for advancement
clear.
And that's all disappeared.
And I see lots of young people
running a business as, I think,
the only full time
capitalist on this panel,
and the degree of
uncertainty that I see
desperation that I
see of people with
loans they can't
pay for jobs they are unable to
procure in a society that does
not offer upward mobility, as
Bill suggested, I think gives
rise to a level of frustration
that goes well beyond going
to Constitutional
principles, and raises
real issues of
anger, frustration,
and bitterness in a country
with changing demographics,
with a population that
is restive in ways
that we had never
anticipated see
mass incarceration, a new
civil rights movement.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Also
notice that the person who
ran as the candidate the
present for the Republican Party
last time was in favor of all
the entitlements actually going
up, told people how they
could have free health
care that would be cheap.
He just had some answer to it.
He ran-- I mean, he was
lying the entire time,
but he ran on a far more
progressive platform,
and also against free trade,
than any previous Republican
ever had.
So if the Republican Party has
turned that left on economics,
what do you expect the
Democratic Party to do?
Now, it's obscured because
the Republican Party right now
is just this cult. And because
in power, the Republican Party
did the reverse.
It actually intensified
social inequality
and intensified climate
change deliberately, kind
of mind blowing.
But in the politics
of it, they definitely
tacked left this time.
RONALD J. PESTRITTO: OK.
Next question, please.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I grew up in high school and
college in the early '70s.
And when I was in school, there
was a huge leftist movement
going on at the time,
anti-war, anti-Vietnam.
Youth, the Baby Boomers,
were the largest generation
to come forward, and everyone
predicted a seismic shift
in politics to the left.
I recall the election of 1972
with a fairly unpopular Richard
Nixon in the press and among
the colleges and the elite,
and I remember a
professor of history
from Wisconsin, George McGovern,
being the vaunted savior,
and income equality
and income guarantees
being a substantial
part of his platform
as well as being what, in
fact, he was promoting.
Now I see Elizabeth Warren,
I see Bernie Sanders,
and I see Donald Trump.
And your projection, Andrew,
about the inevitability
of the Millennials
turning left reminds
me of another Tory, Winston
Churchill, and his comment
about those in their youth not
being left versus those as they
come of age not being right.
I don't see the inevitability
of the Millennial generation
and the success of Z
generation remaining left.
I think the reality is that
conservative nationalism is
a progression that is bringing
great results in this country.
How do you address the
historical paradigm?
DOUGLAS SCHOEN:
Well, Nixon didn't
govern as a right winger.
That's for sure.
If you look at his record,
many of us on the left,
when you strip out
Watergate and you strip out
the unpleasant nature of
much of what Nixon said,
would be very happy with a
economic and social record that
was quite moderate, hence
his 49-state victory.
And I would just ask you to
turn your clock a little forward
to the '74 election when
there was a sea change,
and even to '76 when
Jimmy Carter was
elected as a southern
governor promising
he would never lie to us.
Now, I'm not suggesting
that Jimmy Carter represents
what we in the Democratic
Party stand for.
He most assuredly does not.
But there was a
dramatic reaction
in the '70s against what the
Nixon presidency produced.
And indeed, because Nixon
governed as a centrist,
we ended up in 1980 with a
continuation of a movement
in the Republican Party
started by Barry Goldwater
to the right.
You had Proposition
13 in 1978, and you
had the nomination and election
of Ronald Reagan in 1980.
So as I see that history, I see
it quite different than you do.
But I would also
tell you that it's
going to be pretty hard for
me, as I look at the poll data
and see the Millennials
2 to 1 left, also
with no strength of their
Democratic allegiance--
a lot of them call
themselves independents not
because they're
really independent,
but because they're not
aligned with any of the two
major parties.
So I think if you
just try to believe
that political nationalism
of the type Trump is pushing
is going to command a
majority of the Millennials,
I think you're
overstating the case.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: And let
me add one other thing,
that for the first time,
the Republican Party now
stands for massive borrowing.
The one thing that
socialism was always about,
as Margaret Thatcher said, was
spending other people's money.
But there has never
been a president
who has spent other people's
money quite as wantonly
as the current one.
Now, it's perfectly
massive amounts
of spending and huge tax
cuts to the super wealthy.
That's what he's done.
When you have said,
it doesn't matter
what the budget deficit is.
We can run a trillion
dollar deficit every year,
and we know the Republican
Party will still cheer us.
Of course, there's an opening
on the left to say, well,
if there's all that money
around you just found,
even though we were massively
in debt when you came to office
and we were in a
period of growth,
and you still borrowed all that
money to throw at the economy,
why can't you-- and just
for the very wealthy--
why can't you do
it for the poor?
Why can't you do it
for the working class?
That's such a powerful argument.
And I think that the Republicans
have completely ceded
the party of
responsibility, as it
were, the party of,
we can't afford that,
the party of, no, we
have to have limits.
That is not the current
Republican Party,
actually hasn't been
for a very long time.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Let
me, since Andrew and I
have disagreed on
some points, let
me agree emphatically with him
on the point that he just made.
And here is the
bill of particulars.
I think we all remember then
candidate Donald Trump's
famous down the escalator
announcement speech.
At least, we remember what
he said about Mexicans.
At least, I do.
What we forget is something
that he said later
in the announcement
speech, and you
can check it for
yourselves, namely,
that we have to save Social
Security and Medicare
and Medicaid "without cuts."
I quote.
And then he went on to
say, we've got to do it.
And an important part of the
meaning of Donald Trump's
nomination and election
was the direct repudiation
of the economic
and fiscal policies
of the previous leader
of the Republican Party,
namely Paul Ryan.
Trumpism on economics
is the rejection
of Ryanism on entitlements,
on the budget deficit,
and on trade.
And that move in
the Republican Party
has fundamentally reshaped the
terrain of American politics
and the competition
between the two parties.
And I think we're
just beginning to work
through the
implications of that.
Whether we can live with
economic policies that
are indifferent to
the sorts of things
that Paul Ryan was trying
to do something about
is another question altogether,
but that's where we are.
RONALD J. PESTRITTO: We have
time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for this very
interesting debate.
I did not go to
Hillsdale College.
We support Hillsdale.
I am probably the last
person that should
get up and talk about politics.
So I will not.
The title of this
conference today
was The Future of
the Democratic Party.
I have heard the word Marxism.
I hear the word socialism.
I agree with you, sir.
There has been no one of the
27,000 Democratic people that
are up there talking
about a platform
that I learned back in somewhat,
I think, my younger years.
So I ask you, if you are
going to end this, tell me,
is socialism for the
Democratic Party the future?
And is that socialism defined?
Because that also can be, when
it's on steroids, communism,
and that is something we fought
for years to rid ourselves of.
So I ask you with your
intelligence, your study,
and your backgrounds,
what is the future
of the Democratic Party?
[APPLAUSE]
DOUGLAS SCHOEN: I'll take
a shot at that quickly.
I think we are going to see the
advocacy of socialist policies
by the Democrats, by their
left wing, by the Squad,
by Bernie Sanders,
Elizabeth Warren,
continue unabated through
this election whether we win,
lose, or draw.
I don't think that we're going
to be a communist society.
I think there's very little
chance of that, though I didn't
think Venezuela was going
to end up with Maduro,
either, though I see no
evidence that his cronies will
do anything but end up in
our federal penitentiaries
where many of them belong
for drug trafficking.
That being said, capitalism
isn't going away here.
I think Bill's largely
right, that it will
face challenges and survive.
My point is only
those challenges
are going to be more pronounced,
more continual, and more
vexatious than I think most
Democrats, and certainly
this Democrat,
would like to see.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: I
don't think I would
call the proposals of, say,
Elizabeth Warren socialism,
and this is why.
Do you think Margaret
Thatcher was a socialist?
She presided over free health
care for absolutely everyone
and defended it through
a socialist delivery
system for three terms.
Was Britain socialist
under Margaret Thatcher?
I don't think so.
Is public availability
of health care popular?
Hugely popular.
What is Boris Johnson doing now?
Promising to spend
millions and millions
and millions of dollars
on the health care system
so that everyone can have
access to health care.
Universal access to health
care is not socialism.
It has been the foundation of
every other Western society.
But I do think that it will
become more redistributionist,
and I do think it's going
to become more leftist,
and I do think it's
going to culturally,
because the right has done
such a terrible job of engaging
the next generations,
is going to be
much more culturally
and socially to the left
than we've ever seen before.
WILLIAM A. GALSTON: Well,
I guess it leaves it
to me to end this discussion.
I think I've been pretty
clear that I don't think
that the future of the
country is socialist,
let alone communist.
And I don't think the future
of the Democratic Party
is that, either.
What we are going through
right now within the party
and within the
country is an effort--
and I think this is what our
party system is all about--
to struggle with very
real public problems.
If the economy is not
working well for everybody--
by the way, if it had been
working well for everybody,
Donald Trump would
never have been elected
president of the United States.
He represented a
response to the failure
of the country over
a period of decades
under Republican and
Democratic presidents
to deal with the problems
afflicting the manufacturing
sector of the country,
to deal with the problems
of rural America, the
absence of capital investment
in those areas, et cetera.
He represented one response to
a very uneven economic terrain.
And the Democrats
are now wrestling
about what their response to the
same set of problems should be.
We will not end up with
socialism on the left.
fascism on the right.
But within 10 years,
I think we will
see very significant adjustments
to the market system, much more
aggressive antitrust policy.
Yes, I agree with Andrew, more
emphasis on redistribution
for those people who
are working full time
and not making it
in today's economy.
We are likely to see a
real adjustment of finance
for higher education,
which is now in trouble
because, in response to
the financial crisis,
virtually every state responded
with huge cuts in subsidies
to higher education,
shifting those burdens
to students and their families.
Those are the real debates
we're going to have.
And I think that hundreds of
years of bettors have gone
broke betting against the
capacity of the United States
to assess and, as
Winston Churchill put it,
when all other
alternatives are exhausted,
to do the right thing.
Thank you very much.
RONALD J. PESTRITTO: Thank you.
So we're going to
reconvene at 10:30.
So please enjoy a
break in the interim,
and join me in thanking
these gentlemen
for giving us some very
good things to think about.
[APPLAUSE]